un cheval rosa bascule une machine à
laver ou encore un instrument de musique
originale l'exposition ce que malek va
être présentée au centre d'art de l'ong
de vélizy villacoublay le collectif le
wonder créé en 2013 à travailler avec le
théâtre pour réaliser ses oeuvres ce
groupe d'artistes habitent des bâtiments
inoccupés transformer ces espaces
inutilisés en atelier pour le combat
pour travailler le bois le métal
pression la peinture l'enjeu pour le le
monde heures à chaque phase c'est de
sortir un peu de l'exposition de son
carcan
institutionnel on va dire oui à cette
visite solennelle qui l'a se transforme
en quelque chose qui vient à puiser dans
l'idée du heat ce sont donc 12 artistes
qui ont exposé une petite quinzaine
d'oeuvres totalement différente où tous
les sens sont en éveil elles ont tout de
même 2 point en commun être expérimental
est destiné à un public plutôt jeune
l'idée c'était vraiment d'apporter une
dimension ludique c'est pas un collectif
qui travaillent spécialement pour le
jeune public donc c'était vraiment une
demande une commande du centre d'art et
de léo
qui touche aussi c'est public l'a donc
sont vraiment amusé avec ça mais ça me
permet ce qu a créé crystal meth en 2010
est une oeuvre hypnotisante une boule
disco accrochés au plafond qui crée un
frottement sur le sable ce qui
m'intéresse dans celle de la mettre en
jeu à londres le plafond encore une fois
il est très très haut donc est vraiment
ces questions aussi l'art là une très
grande chine qui descendait pour venir
et épouser la danse cette boule disco
sur le sol qui vient en fait briser ce
miroir et se brise et ensuite ses
miroirs dans un espèce de bruit de ce
crash de vinyle produit une fine
poussière de 2,2 de miroir argenté
d'autres oeuvres ludiques sont proposées
comme un mur du son des tiroirs qui
s'ouvre et se ferme en rythme ou encore
une rechute de culture de champignons
toutes ces réalisations sont à découvrir
jusqu'au 14 janvier prochain